okay Donald Trump's approval rating has
surged to the best of his presidency say
the headlines in the Gallup presidential
approval poll okay so in the Gallup
presidential approval poll Donald Trump
is now polling 49% approval this is as
of Tuesday morning which was before the
State of the Union address reality show
extravaganza that he did on Tuesday
night and before his acquittal on
impeachment yesterday so we don't yet
know how those two events will affect
his approval rating fifty percent
according to the Gallup poll disapprove
of Trump forty nine percent approve so a
lot of trumpets have gone absolutely
crazy because of this and believe that
Donald Trump is clearly a shoo-in for
re-election in November and of course
they may be completely correct but what
it is important to understand is that
this is just gallup it's much more
informative and contextualized to look
at an aggregate of Donald Trump's
presidential approval and if you look at
the aggregate both nationally among all
Americans or even among likely voters
the approval rating has not moved very
much for Donald Trump so let's look
closely and as you can see from the 538
aggregate from approval rating there
really hasn't been I would say not much
of an uptick there's really been no
uptick and Donald Trump's approval
rating is actually still on average
lower right now than it was in
mid-november now you can also counter by
saying if Trump's approval is
historically low for a long period of
time when it becomes more normal it
looks like a big increase but that
actually ignores the data which is that
Donald Trump's approval rating is
basically steady but the really
important thing to think about here is
not actually whether Trump's real
approval rating is at 49 47 or 42 the
most important message to take away from
this is that regardless of whether it's
at 49 47 or 42 re-election remains
likely for an incumbent president with
an approval rating in the 40s
the increase or decrease or the shift or
the exact number that's less
important what matters is that George W
Bush was re-elected in the year 2004
despite being relatively unpopular now
there is no question that one can make
the case that it was because of
irregularities only in the state of Ohio
which he won narrowly and had he lost
John Kerry would have become President
of the United States but regardless it
came down to just a hundred thousand
votes in Ohio even with Donald george w
bush not a particularly popular
president a Barack Obama at this point
in his presidency in the same Gallup
presidential approval poll was at only
forty six percent approval while Donald
Trump again is at forty nine so the
important takeaways are it is really
difficult to knock out an incumbent
president even with an approval rating
in the 40s we've talked before about how
you can make the mathematical case where
a president could actually be reelected
even with an approval rating in the low
30s or the high 20s now it would be
unlikely because you need high support
in certain states and then you can
mathematically have almost no support in
certain state like you can do it because
of the Electoral College it's not the
most likely scenario but if it's
possible to be re-elected with a thirty
percent approval rating with a forty
nine percent of forty seven percent or
forty three percent wherever it is you
believe Donald Trump actually is it is
no sweat to get yourself reelected so
this stuff really matters now in the
next week to two weeks what I want to
pay close attention to is what happens
to Donald Trump's approval in the in the
aggregate overall now that he has been
acquitted in impeachment and after that
State of the Union address and several
very good days in the stock market and
as we know the stock market something
that in practice affects way fewer
people than it effects in ideology and
for PR purposes people see the stock
market climbing even if they don't have
shares of stock they still start to
believe that it's because of something
that the president is doing so what do
we need to do well if the Democratic
primaries continue being a fiasco if the
economy stays
superficially strong and it's important
to know that I'm using the term
superficially it is going to be a tough
uphill battle to knock out Donald Trump
in November the reality with impeachment
is that impeachment was the right thing
constitutionally it was the right thing
from the point of view of this is a
responsibility of the House of
Representatives to bring impeachment
charges when the facts support them and
warrant them the reality is that we have
to figure out a way to win and the other
reality is that it is not surprising or
unexpected that polling support for the
president would consolidate as we close
in on the election particularly if the
Democratic Party continues to be framed
not totally inaccurately
as inept in its ability to just conduct
a simple primary whereas of this
recording we still do not have results a
full three days after the Iowa caucuses
completed in Iowa so do I am I giving up
am I suggesting anyone give up of course
not of course not
but what I am Telling You is that there
are a real obstacles here to removing
Donald Trump another one will certainly
be that there is going to be foul play
there is already voter suppression the
tactics and these strategies are already
being employed and if Donald Trump does
lose in November I do not believe that
he is going to go peacefully I don't
believe there will be a peaceful
transition the way we have defined it in
the United States for hundreds of years
and that's what I'm going to talk about
after the break make sure you're
following the David Pakman show on
Instagram for more on this and every
other story from today's show at David
Pakman show on Instagram while you're
there I mean well you've got the app
pulled up I mean follow me on Instagram
as well at David Pakman